So most of us think that information is the
best way to convince people of our truth,
and in fact it doesn’t work that well.We
see that all the time.
We see it with climate change, where there’s
tons of data suggesting that climate change
is man-made but about 50 percent of the population
doesn’t believe it, or with people arguing
about things like how many people were in
the presidential inauguration.
So we have facts but people decide which facts
they want to listen to, which facts they want
to take and change their opinions, and which
they want to disregard.
And one of the reasons for this is when something
doesn’t conform to what I already believe,
what people tend to do is either disregard
it or rationalize it away; because information
doesn’t take into account what makes us
human, which is our emotions, our desires,
our motives and our prior beliefs.
So for example, in one study my colleagues
and I tried it to see whether we could use
science to change people’s opinions about
climate change.
The first thing we did was ask people, “Do
you believe in man-made climate change?
Do you support the Paris Agreement?”
And based on their answers we divided them
into the strong believers and the weak believers.
And then we gave them information.
For some people we said that scientists have
reevaluated the data and now conclude that
things are actually much worse than they thought
before, that the temperature would rise by
about seven degrees to ten degrees.
For some people we said the scientists have
reevaluated the data and they now believe
that actually this situation is not as bad
as they thought, it’s much better, and the
rise in temperature would be quite small.
And what we found is that people who did not
believe in climate change, when they heard
that the scientists are saying, “Actually
it’s not that bad,” they changed their
beliefs even more in that direction, so they
became more extremist in that direction, but
when they heard that the scientists think
it’s much worse they didn’t nudge.
And the people who already believe that climate
change is man-made, when they heard that scientists
are saying things are much worse than they
said before, they moved more in that direction,
so they became more polarized, but when they
heard scientists are saying it’s not that
bad they didn’t nudge much.
So we gave people information and as a result
it caused polarization, it didn’t cause
people to come together.
So the question is, what’s happening inside
our brain that causes this?
And in one study my colleagues and I scanned
brain activity of two people who were interacting,
and what we found was when those two people
agreed on a question that we gave them, the
brain was really encoding what the other person
was saying, the details that they gave; but
when the two people disagreed it looked metaphorically
as if the brain was switching off and not
encoding what the other person was saying.And
as a result when the two agreed they became
even more confident, but when they disagreed
there wasn’t as much of a change in their
confidence in their own view.
What has been shown by Kahan and colleagues
from Yale University is that the more intelligent
you are the more likely you are to change
data at will.
So what they did is they first gave participants
in their experiment analytical and math questions
to solve, and then they gave them data about
gun control: is gun control actually reducing
violence?
And they found that more “intelligent”
people actually were more likely to twist
data at will to make it conform to what they
already believed.So it seems that people are
using their intelligence not necessarily to
find the truth, but to take in the information
and change it to conform to what they already
believe.
So that suggests that just giving people information
without considering first where they’re
coming from may backfire at us, but we don’t
always need to go against someone’s conviction
in order to change their behavior, and let
me give you an example.
So this is a study that was conducted at UCLA
where what they wanted to do is convince parents
to vaccinate their kids.
And some of the parents didn’t want to vaccinate
their kids because they were afraid of the
link with autism.So they had two approaches,
first they said, “Well the link with autism
is actually not real, here’s all the data
suggesting there isn’t a link between vaccines
and autism.”
And it didn’t really work that well.
But instead they used another approach.
So instead of going that way they used another
approach, which was: let’s not talk about
autism, we don’t necessarily need to talk
about autism to convince you to vaccinate
your kids.
Instead they said, “Well look, these vaccines
protect kids from deadly diseases, from the
measles,” and they showed them pictures
of what the measles are.
Because in this argument about vaccines people
actually forgot what the vaccines are for,
what are they protecting us from.
And they highlighted that and didn’t necessarily
go on to discuss autism.
That had a much better outcome.
The parents were much more likely to say,
“Yes we are going to vaccinate our kids.”
So the lesson here is that we need to find
the common motive.
The common motive in this case was the health
of the children, not necessarily going back
to the thing that they were arguing about,
that they disagreed about.